the beer that you're taking is in at
least 25 bars in the city right now and
the guy said well where are they said
I'm not telling you that i am nick
gillespie with reason TV and we are in
the Kensington section of Philadelphia
at the memphis taproom with brendan
heart ramp the owner of the memphis
taproom you're a businessman what's your
business my wife and I operate three
craft beer bars and restaurants in
Philadelphia were decidedly in
neighborhoods which you know for those
people that don't know Philadelphia that
well we're out of the you know the
central area or you know the financial
zone we'd prefer to be in you know kind
of more residential neighborhoods and
Philadelphia so you've got the memphis
taproom in kensington we had the local
44 in west philly and we have the
resurrection ale house in grace ferry
Brendan what what happened why are we
talking to you well would you you know
in addition to you know a lot of other
people you know the past two months
we've been talking to a lot of folks
about you know what kind of happened to
us and and what happened was everyone
saying raided by the PLCB I really
prefer to call it an on-site
investigation so what were they looking
for what were they invest they had
gotten an anonymous tip that we were
selling unregistered beer okay explain
what's the concept of an unregistered
vehicle concept of unregistered beer
isn't really that bizarre of a concept I
mean you're moving alcohol you know and
that's something that was controlled by
the ATF but after nine eleven it turned
into a different organization but
everyone's got to register you know what
they're doing it's you know it's a
controlled substance and it's something
that you know every state and city make
some money off so registration is a way
that they can you know get 75 bucks per
okay and so every beer maker has to they
register each particular brand of beer
that they bottle and sell exactly
about 75 bucks 75 bucks per brand per
year and you were selling unregistered
beer I would without a doubt what kind
of what was the beer it was it well it
was actually it was a pretty it was a
pretty big sweep you know I mean there
was some stuff that was out of one of my
locations that was you know what like a
multi you know national international
brand a new name oh yeah well hawker
sure was unregistered and hopper sure is
in a massive beer you can get it you can
get has one chance the the maker is
responsible for registering the brewery
and the brewer is responsible for
registry so it's not that you you fail
to register it say you were moving and
unregistered product we were yet we're
selling an unregistered to you know it
was unregistered none of the time yeah
yeah but i but it did all things being
fair i was aware of the registration
process you know and you know I knew
that that's you know what had to happen
for a beer to come into our market so I
wasn't completely unfamiliar with the
idea of a brain but you assume if you're
buying it from a wholesaler they states
are to be rushed okay so then they come
in they investigate what happened my
taser I wasn't fazed no I was stunned
but mainly by the fact that they were
here travelodge but psychologically stun
they'd come in and they said that they
they had a you know an anonymous tip
that they were so we were selling
unregistered beer and they asked to you
know pretty much check out our inventory
and I think that it was something I
think there were a little shocked when
they looked at the size of our inventory
and figuring out you know what was you
know how to figure out what was
registered and what wasn't they had come
with a very crude list of what they must
have just pulled off our website as far
as what we had on draft and you know the
plce is actually who came out there in
the enforcement arm of the the
Pennsylvania Liquor Control Board and it
was a you know just a very crude
cross-check of what may or may not have
been registered so to give you an idea
it was it was essentially like a
spreadsheet on eight and a half 11 piece
of paper and it you know it said like
the name of a beer
and then in the comment cell of the
spreadsheet it would say you know might
be registered or not registered or
register hoppy malty no no that would be
that would have been nice what how much
did you end up getting fine we that is
still kind of ongoing they have a year
to figure out what our punishment is and
you pay the fine not the brewer or the
brewer also I will be I will be held
responsible there's something in
Pennsylvania if you're a license holder
you're governed by what's called strict
liability so you know the the onus is on
me it's what happens going forward how
does this affect you as a businessman do
you now take more or less care of the
same amount of care and making sure your
brands are well the brand registration
is really you know now everyone because
of you know the impact of it you know
everyone is making sure that it's
registered before it even gets to me so
you know it's no I mean obviously we're
checking you know I'm checking every day
to make sure so I mean it you know it's
another five minutes out of my day to
make sure that you know I got everything
you know taking care of the thing that
you know really resonates with me about
the whole thing and what I do think
about on a daily basis is that whoever
placed these calls is familiar enough
with the laws that you know it all it
leads me to believe that they're also
you know operating the craft beer
industry and you know that that just
scares me to death because you know what
we're doing is pretty specific you know
and it's kind of predicated on the idea
that we're all in it together so then
what I mean what you're what you're
getting at is that these rules can
actually be you know the explicit nature
of them is to protect or to keep track
of you know beer etc but they can
actually be used by competitors or by
the government or an authority to shut
you down and you alone well me and well
that's kind of how it worked out now I
mean I could have played it differently
I could have you know when the PLC you
guys were here I easily could have said
hey well this bar this but yeah I said
to the guy said hey the beer that you're
taking is in at least 25 bars in the
city right now and the guy said well
where are they said I'm not
you that you know but it's a you
certainly wouldn't expect a member of
the Liquor Control Board to have any
idea of where to find bars right well
you know I mean that would part of the
thing you know that was a little
frustrating with it was that you know
when they wrote these you know laws from
registration it was like 50 breweries in
the country you know and now what
they're doing they're using those same
laws to control you know we we
understand that they need to control but
they're using the same laws to control
what's now you know almost 1300
breweries in the country you know I mean
we're not getting all those beers but
you know there's a lot more beer than
there was you know 20 years ago a lot
more balloon was ten years ago well
let's let's end it here for ISA TV at
the memphis taproom in Kensington
Philadelphia i'm nick gillespie brennan
heart raft
you